while there's really no way to tell if
someone's lying so there's no way to
spot deception say up you're not telling
the truth
and there's no such thing as the
Pinocchio's nose of lying no one sign
that will tell you this person is not to
be trusted but there we can learn to
recognize some of the persuasive
techniques that people might use to try
to get get us on their side
unfortunately it starts with getting us
to like them and so once you like
someone it's much more difficult to spot
these things because you're already
subjective but how do people get you to
like them well we like people who are
similar to us and we like people who
like the things we like we like people
who are familiar to us you know I've
seen you around you know I know who you
are and people who are trying to sell us
something be they con artists or just
softer salespeople they know this and so
they latch on to characteristics about
us that are pretty apparent you know
they might find out that I'm from the
Boston area and say oh the Red Sox try
to see my reaction am I an avid Red Sox
fan if I am that the conversation will
now go in that direction all of a sudden
we're bonding over baseball this can't
be a bad person and now all of a sudden
they're selling me something but now
from a very different point of view from
a point of view of a friend of someone
who's a buddy of someone who's really
cool rather than the point of view of
someone who's a salesperson so that's
something to be on the lookout although
it's terrible because I'm basically
saying hey you know don't make new
friends but what I mean is if a
friendship advances very very quickly
and on very superficial basis and is
followed very soon thereafter by a
request then that might be a red flag
that the request might not might be
something that you want to think twice
about then there are ways of framing
requests that we know are more likely to
be successful for instance there's a
technique that's called the foot in the
door get your foot in the door and then
you can ask for what you really want so
how do you get the foot in the door
first you
for something really really small so I
might ask you for just two minutes of
your time I want your opinion on you
know purchase I'm making and I know that
I really trust your opinion on cell
phones so can you just help me out do
like your phone you know can you what do
you like about it okay wonderful thank
you so much we're done a few weeks later
you might ask me to you know donate or
or rather I might ask you since I'm the
one who's the con artist in this
scenario I might ask you to you know
write me a letter of recommendation or
donate an hour of your time to a
volunteer organization I work for or
whatever my real ask is but because
you've helped me in the past even though
it was a very very small favor that you
were asking you're much more likely to
help me now because we like to be
consistent and if we think that we're
nice people who help others because
we've already helped someone we're going
to keep helping plus if I'm the type of
person who was worth helping once I'm
worth helping again because clearly you
didn't make the wrong decision the first
time around so rebate requests are
really hard to say no to but sometimes
we have to sometimes you have to realize
that you know what just because I said
yes once doesn't mean that I should say
yes a second time and it doesn't make me
a bad person to say no it's one of those
things that you have to give yourself
permission to say no and you have to
give yourself permission to exit
situations that we don't feel
comfortable in there's a technique
called the door in the face which is the
opposite of the foot in the door so you
ask for something egregious you know I
don't really know you very well but I'm
going to ask you to spend a day at the
zoo with my students and you're going to
say are you insane in your mind you
probably wouldn't say this to my face
but you're certainly going to say no
because that's something that's really a
huge huge amount of time and so then a
few weeks later I'll say oh no no of
course I totally understand it was you
know it's a huge imposition I totally
get it don't worry about it a few weeks
later I come back to you and say hey
would you be willing to come in and talk
my class for an hour and then you know
answer some questions you're going to
say yes even though that's a huge
request still and if I had just asked
you that you probably would have said no
but you're still feeling so guilty about
saying no the first time around even
though I said that I really didn't mind
and that I totally understood you're
going to be feeling so guilty that
you're going to say yes
during the face first you slam that make
them slam the door in your face because
slamming the door in someone's face
feels terrible and we hate feeling like
that human being so then we'll try to
redeem ourselves and then we'll become
your best friend we'll keep helping you
once again something that uses human
emotion and our perception of ourselves
against us we want to feel like good
people con artists know this and they
take advantage of it
by making us do things that will make us
feel a good people and putting us in
situations where it's really difficult
to refuse because refusing would mean
we're not good people and that's not a
feeling that we're comfortable with at
all they also love using you know if we
if we talk about other argumentative
strategies a lot of it has to do with
scarcity you know get it while it's hot
this isn't going to last
whenever anyone puts time pressure on
you that's a really bad sign now I know
that certain companies when they're
making you a job offer they'll make it
an exploding offer so this job offer is
only on the table for the next 48 hours
and if you don't take it it's gone a lot
of people will take that job offer
whereas if they had a moment to cool
down and to think about it they would
have realized that it's not good for
them and well you would think that
employers aren't con artists but that's
a page right out of the con artists
playbook how do you pressure people into
doing something that they might not
otherwise do for your own ends because
you want that person to take this job
well if you really wanted them but you
were playing you know if you were
playing by the rulebook you would give
them time to think about it making it an
exploding offer puts them in a situation
where again there emotionally hot they
can't reflect and so they can't they
feel like they can't say
because what happens you know we're
right back with uncertainty what happens
if I have no job
what happens if nothing else comes up
and I say no I can't run that risk this
might not be quite right for me but I'm
just going to accept it
con-artists put us in that situation all
the time then they just fill the world
with exploding job offers people who are
trying to persuade us whether they're
con artists whether they're our business
people whether they're our sales people
whether they're politicians they really
key in on the human desire to say yes
and the fact that we often just don't
want to exit a situation because we
don't know how we don't know how to get
out of it and still feel like good
people still maintain our dignity and so
knowing how to say no is I think the
crucial lesson that we can learn for
extra cating ourselves out of a lot of
these persuasive situations
you